[Music]
good morning Hank it's Monday April 30th
a lot of people wanted to say hi to you
this weekend so I let him hey there Hank
um this time I'm not hanging from a fire
escape being chased by the police so
this is really an improvement
sayako good morning Hank now that my
editor and a bunch of other authors have
said hello to you I have a surprise good
morning Hank and good morning Kelly is
Francesca hi have a really good day Hank
that was Francesca Lia block the author
of wheat Eve at a book I know you like
and I know I like and I also know that
Brotherhood 2.0 viewer Kelly likes
speaking of Francesca Lia block Judy
Blume might have just been knocked out
of my guilt-free three and now for our
final introduction I think you're really
cute and I know you're married okay
because you mentioned in your video last
week it was totally massively illegal
for me to try to record the Los Angeles
Times book prizes on video so I had to
do it really service Li and as you can
see I did a really wonderful job with
the camerawork I don't like to brag but
if they give out a Los Angeles Times
Book Prize for the best bootleg
recording of the Los Angeles Times Book
Prizes I am definitely going to win so
first Jackie Woodson the presenter
introduced each of the five finalists
the rules of survival Tyrell the
astonishing life of Octavian nothing an
abundance of katherines
and just in case and then came the
moment we've all been waiting for and by
we I mean the 30 people in the audience
who care about young adult literature
it's bad it will fall into the hands of
those kids who really do not see
themselves represented in Leawood
Sherlock and my hope also
congratulations Co moving on Hank I have
a challenge for you the Yeti and I have
both been singing the Helen Hunt song
pretty much non-stop for the last five
days I want to give you a brief sense of
what it's like to be at our house right
now thank you nervous I'm trying to find
a house anyway Hank we sing the song
constantly we can't get it out of our
heads the only problem is that we can't
quite sing it in key because it seems to
have been written in the key of awesome
and so Hank that brings me my challenge
I would like to challenge you to make
more songs lots more but what I need
right now is for you to write a song
that will replace the Helen Hunt song
because it's starting to burn a hole in
my head oh hey Hank by the way you know
what's funnier than dogs in New York
that's right
dogs in Los Angeles look at it Hank
it's a chihuahua that seems to be
married to a 19th century plantation
owner